broken [ __ ] character there you're
just a [ __ ] scrub look that was me of
my lowest point I'm not proud of it but
we've all been there you're playing a
game and you start to feel like you're
losing control maybe it kicks off
because of a mistake a teammate makes or
maybe it's something someone says to you
or maybe the game is just trash because
you know it's impossible you're the
problem right but it doesn't matter
you're free falling towards rage and
you're probably going to lose
there's simply no hope for you or is
there I'm Miles Hackett a recovering
rageaholic and today with the help of
two highly qualified professionals I'm
going to show you how to just say no to
till Tilt is the scourge of competitors
everywhere and it affects everyone from
the hopeless bottom dwellers of bronze
tier all the way up to the apex
predators of the eSports world no one is
immune to frustration most people think
that tilt originates in poker but it can
be traced even further back to pinball
prior to 1947 the earliest pinball
machines didn't have flippers so players
had to physically tilt them in order to
direct the ball but over time with the
obsession of setting a new high score
people took tilting too far and it took
a toll on the machines to extend their
lifespans manufacturers introduced
flippers and then eventually slammed
tilt switch mechanisms that would end
the game if players got a little too
carried away as pen heads moved away
from tilting to nudging techniques tilt
became slang for playing poorly or
becoming so angry that you trigger the
machines game-ending mechanism
eventually help made its way from the
seedy bars and arcades of the 70s to
high-stakes poker tables where it took
on the meaning we associate it with
today in poker tilt describes somebody
who's become emotionally affected by
losing money which typically leads to
extremely aggressive play and ends in
spectacular bouts of rage she's handling
it with some brace she'll take home over
ninety one thousand dollars for her
third place according to cognitive
psychologists and poker tilt expert and
legend ranked hearthstone player dr. you
see Paulo Marquis Hilton poker always
starts with a significant monetary loss
it makes you want to enter the box pop
more often because you feel but the
quicker you get back what was what you
believe was yours the better it would be
for you you have the urge to get back
what you believe is yours in the name of
justice and that means you need to enter
more pots need to play more aggressively
while it's difficult to pinpoint exactly
when tilt meet its way from poker to
gaming if you consider the shared
competitive nature of the two it's not
hard to see how it happened and with the
rise in popularity of online ranked
matchmaking systems in the early 2000s a
currency has emerged that has become
more important to gamers than money MMR
I lost a hundred and fifty points of Evo
I took all of the teams a low loss and
put it on my shoulders think about it
what do you do when you see that number
drop that's right you get back in the
[ __ ] cube this primal drive to
reclaim what we feel has been wrongly
taken from us can be tied back to our
earliest evolutionary instinct when
you're cavemen ancestors had something
taken away from them their natural
reaction was to rage and get it
otherwise they wouldn't survive Paula
Mackey believes that when you're in full
control of a situation you shouldn't
necessarily tell them but losing when
you feel like you shouldn't that can be
what pushes you over the edge this would
be very difficult you just have like any
time to work with the bomb press could
take five seconds alone he's gonna go
for it behind the fountain Carragher
just gonna charge him down is it miss
quite a few pistol shots Kenny yes II
wanna kill the round in most competitive
games tilt can be the greatest barrier
separating you from success and just as
there are different causes for tilt
their varying degrees of it as well most
of us start off at the standard 90
degrees that's when you're not tilted at
all next is 45 degrees also known as the
acute tilt this is pretty much the point
where you've started to become
destabilized that's followed then by the
obtuse tilt a state involving acts like
yelling at your teammates getting
physical it's a big slam and generally
playing far below your usual ability
and finally we have the 180 The Full
Tilt also known as pure rage oh my god
you should be aware that there's an AWP
still oh no what am i doing Lynden
alcoholic it's only game you have to be
mad as crazy as some of these examples
might look just remember that tilting is
normal and everyone experiences it even
Paula Mackey admits to being a
recovering tilter poker poker back in
2009 my worst tilting experience was
probably something like taking a pillow
yelling into Dennis as hard it's not
kind of ending up with it actually a
headache that lasted for a couple of
days in that I was like theory did I
give myself a stroke or something and
and that that was like okay yeah this is
I need to I need to re-evaluate my
position here but as damning as going
full-tilt usually is you can recover
from it it's actually possible to tilt
so hard that you can return to a pure
Zen --until big state look no further
than the grand final series of the 2018
Styx Invitational where evil geniuses
were up 2-0 and Penta appeared to be
falling to failure one goes down hey who
doesn't look sees the mutant across the
Canadian it's fine to for eg and neck
Rock still a contestant
I'm like tilted quiet
fabien said there is streaming like what
the [ __ ] we'll be doing we're so
terrible you do better do you guys wanna
[ __ ] news I don't want a [ __ ]
loser cause I'm win now right but it
kind of throw it out everybody's
frustrations we kind of yelled at each
other we've got everything I thought you
did this you did that
I said no [ __ ] that thank you whichever
and then he says the overnight I don't
want you to lose do you and I think it
is click like no we don't want to do it
as unrecoverable as their collapse
appeared to be Penta sent eg on a full
tilt of their own pulling off the
reverse sweet Penghu and Fabien left two
of the best-known players on that the
Catholics sufficient Fragger Fabien down
its Penghu the apse just waited or
rather the Havanna just waited they'll
look to push together the diffuser in a
position where they'll have to see when
the Habano goes through one will cover
the doorway
[Applause]
failure is an unavoidable obstacle in
life and eSports you simply cannot be
perfect
you'll never win everyone v1 and you
will make mistakes but learning to deal
with the tilt these setbacks can bring
is often the difference between
achieving glorious victory and suffering
crushing defeat and today with
prestigious titles and massive prize
pools on the line many eSports
organizations have brought in team
psychologists perhaps the most obvious
benefactors of this progressive approach
our CS goes astrology mat prior to 2017
had become known for tripping over the
last hurdle we and I especially had a
joking problem can't just keep on saying
that it's unlucky because it's happened
so many times after falling short of
their own expectations at the Boston
major in 2018 Australis added lars Roble
to their support staff in order to help
strengthen the team's mentality and
let's be honest who would know how to do
that better than someone with 20 years
experience in the Danish Special Forces
and then sometimes people ask me okay I
mean what's the difference between cons
dragon and
we'll work its I mean tribal much faster
than counter-strike then it isn't true
so these split decisions that you have
to make this amount of the decisions the
time you have to for the decisions are
different with the amount of
split-second choices and teamwork that
csgo demands momentum in a match can
swing from one round to the next and how
you respond to these feelings in-game is
key to determining your results not that
uncertainty it's not the the frustration
that is the problem it's what the
frustration makes you do but doesn't
make it that is so you gotta accept it
that it's there so when you get this
feeling of now I'm losing control now I
get the feeling of tilting the first
thing you have to do the first image
it's all about technique it's a bit to
register that you are going away from
your game plan and since Lars and the
astrologist affe implemented tilt
management training for the players the
team's overall performances and
successes have been nothing short of
staggering I mean the first time I met a
stylist and we started this journey we
went on a poker with our computers and
we're sitting on an old warship and then
we started defining the dream what is
the do what is it will want to achieve
and then we broke the dream into very
specific very operational targets that
we control ourselves we decide how much
ever we want to put into this focal area
and that gives you that your the feeling
of your EIN control to ensure this sense
of stability and control astrologist
developed a three step program for
managing in-game tilt first you need to
register the feeling of being tilted and
accepted the second step is then
releasing it by recognizing that you're
deviating from your intended game plan
and finally refocusing getting back into
what Lars calls the here and now what I
have seen is that they are much more
present the bad experiences the bad
history that they have I mean that's
been removed also this being able to
have the cars to make decisions on the
edge when zip X disappears it's
clear he's up to no good they know he's
on b-but where his own gun I think block
the vision and now civics knows that
they're working in one above all he's
the lab it's the slaughter and that work
has clearly paid dividends as astrology
themselves from being CS goes notorious
choke artist to the greatest team to
ever play the game so the next time you
feel the same familiar tug of tilt
pulling you down remember to register it
release it and then refocus if it worked
for counter strikes Danish conquerors
I'm sure it can work for you too I mean
it worked for me I'm certifiably
untellable these days doesn't bother me
at all
with the amount of split-second distance
it's like like your bones are made of
pretzels salty
Sean pretzel are I know it's like
everyone that makes smiles jokes
loose kilometres in Canada so [ __ ] you
God